the moment to settle down used to be
when you had a bit of spare money and a
decent job then when things became more
romantic it became all about being
deeply in love with someone but both
these criteria are now heavily outdated
these are the six things you need to do
to signal you're ready to settle down
and have a chance of a successful
long-term relationship the moment to
settle down is when you finally realize
your partner is deeply imperfect they
have a hundred different floors they're
maddening in all sorts of ways and are
riddled with psychological neuroses that
make them very hard to deal with however
there's an important additional
realization everyone is in fact like
this once you get below the charming
outer surface no one else would be
better we're a fundamentally flawed
species there's no such thing as a right
person everyone is wrong in fascinating
and enraging ly diverse ways we think
love is about being understood for all
the secret vulnerable parts of us that
others don't grasp but however much the
other seems to understand us there will
always be huge tracts of our psyches
that remain utterly incomprehensible to
others no one properly understands and
can therefore fully sympathise with
anyone else for a long time it's easy to
pretend one's normal even quite
easygoing but it's time to settle down
when you're mature enough to have an
active sense of what a liability you are
you're out of control for regular
periods you lose perspective you're
anxious all the time
you're mature when you can be deeply
embarrassed about who you are and a
prepare to apologize for the fact on a
regular basis confusingly we speak of
love as one thing when it's in fact to
being loved and loving we should settle
down
when we're finally ready to stop always
wanting to be loved and pick up the
ropes that far less familiar activity
actually loving some the unhelpful
feeling that love is all about being
loved starts in childhood to the child
it feels as if the parent is simply had
spontaneously on hand to comfort
entertain feed clear up and remain
almost always warm and cheerful parents
don't reveal to that kids how often
they've bitten their tongue fought back
the tears and been too tired to take off
their clothes after a day of childcare
the relationship is almost entirely non
reciprocal parent and child may both
love but each party is on a very
different end of the axis unbeknownst to
the child that's why in adulthood when
we first say we long for love what we
predominantly mean is that we want to be
loved as we were once loved bad parent
we want a recreation in adulthood of
what it felt like to be ministered to
and indulged we want someone who will
understand our needs bring us what we
want be immensely patient and
sympathetic to us act selflessly and
make it all better
this is naturally a disaster for a
relationship to work we need to move
firmly out of the child mode and into
the parental one
the romantic person instinctively sees
relationships in terms of emotions but
what a couple actually get up to
together over a lifetime has much more
in common with the workings of a small
business the two people must clean
chauffeur cook fix throw away hire and
budget
none of these activities has any glamour
whatsoever within the current
arrangement of society those obliged to
do them are therefore highly likely to
feel that something has gone wrong with
their lives having to involve themselves
so closely with them and yet these tasks
are truly romantic in a sense of
conducive and sustaining of love you are
the bedrock any successful relationship
at the altar new couples should take a
mutual vow I accept the dignity of the
ironing there's an idea that being loved
it means that your partner will never
try to change but they should and must
want to change you because you're deeply
imperfect and in need of severe
remoulding in all sorts of areas if
you're not ready for it it may look like
hostility and you may respond
defensively but you're ready to settle
down when you can bear to have things
pointed out to you you should at key
points see them as the teacher and use
the pupil and vice versa with neither
side losing their tempers relationships
are meant to be an education towards
becoming to better people not a process
of acceptance for everything one already
is with these dark and sober criteria in
mind we can go back into the world of
relationships assured of a brighter
longer and more realistic future
you